where'd they come from where did we come
from
you wouldn't believe how many guys
wanted to play here
[Music]
ray liotta has died he was 67 years old
i don't have a strong big desire to be
like major major personality
i just hope to get the opportunity to
keep working and you know with some
really interesting parts with some
really great people the actor's
publicist confirmed his death revealing
that he died in his sleep in the
dominican republic where he was shooting
the film dangerous waters i just stayed
with it because i started getting you
know better and better parts and like
anything when you show you know people
show you a little appreciation or that
you did a good job it makes you feel
good and and i stayed leota a new jersey
native had a career that spanned more
than 30 years his first major acting
role something wild which earned him his
first golden globe nomination
charlie yeah you've been on tv uh no ray
i don't think you've ever been untold oh
here's your chance why what you're the
new vice president huh
yeah i am the new vp and don't you
forget him all right we'll make a
[Music]
you're on speech yeah and leota is
perhaps best known for a few iconic
parts like shoeless joe jackson and
field of dreams getting thrown out of
baseball
was like having part of me amputated
i've heard that old men wake up and
scratch itchy legs that have been dust
for over 50 years
that was me i've been fortunate were
well filled up dreams there was a lot of
people in that that were you know
big big star you know kevin and as
real-life mobster henry hill and
goodfellas how am i funny
not just
you know how you tell a story what it
gave me an opportunity to fulfill a
dream to work with scorsese and deniro
and to have a wonderful part and a movie
about henry
it's great fast forward nearly three
decades and many respected performances
later leota echoed a similar sentiment
from his early career days it was such
an indelible
imprint on me because i was working with
people that that became my idols because
when i first started acting in the 70s
it was their movies that that i was
watching with it you know and and and
many others coppola and and like with
like my favorite actors that i've been
lucky enough to work with with gene
hackman and robert duvall and to work
with these people
uh
because because of those movies in the
70s just really made a mark on me the
oda is survived by his fiancee and his
daughter carson
[Music]
you